ah
[Música]
la pandemia de el coronavirus hizo que
millones de ciudadanos en américa
latina' abrieran una cuenta de ahorros y
colombia no es la excepción
la estricta cuarentena vigente por casi
seis meses en el país incrementó el uso
de canales electrónicos pero además el
gobierno realizó transferencias
monetarias que llevaron a muchos
habitantes no solamente a adquirir
productos financieros sino a activar los
que ya tenían en desuso de acuerdo con
la asociación bancaria y de entidades
financieras sólo en el primer semestre
de este año más de 16 millones de
personas debutaron en el sistema
financiero bien sea a través de cuentas
de ahorros o también a través de
créditos esto significa que el 85 por
ciento de los ciudadanos adultos ya
están bancarizados esto quiere decir que
unos 31 millones de colombianos ya están
en el sistema financiero haciendo que la
meta gubernamental se cumpliera dos años
antes de lo previsto
[Música]
en brasil hasta el año pasado más de 45
millones de personas no habían movido su
cuenta bancaria durante más de seis
meses o simplemente no tenían una cuenta
en un banco sin embargo esta realidad
cambió drásticamente con el pago de las
ayudas de emergencia al por medio de
cuentas digitales durante la pandemia
del coronavirus según datos del banco
central de brasil más de 9 millones de
personas han creado una cuenta bancaria
desde el mes de marzo cuando empezó la
pandemia del país en su mayoría personas
de bajos ingresos y las que viven lejos
de las grandes ciudades sin embargo la
inclusión financiera sigue siendo un
desafío en brasil a pesar de la
digitalización de los servicios
bancarios el acceso a internet es
todavía un obstáculo hasta 2018 más del
20% de los hogares brasileños no tenían
internet además el número de las
ciudades sin servicios bancarios se ha
disparado en los últimos años
actualmente hay más de 2000 ciudades
brasileñas sin agencias bancarias un 22
por ciento más que el 2012
[Música]
la tasa de inclusión financiera en
áfrica es la más baja del mundo pero con
la pandemia ha incrementado el uso de
las startups del sector financiero y
también el acceso a las entidades
bancarias el norte de áfrica sería la
región donde la inclusión financiera
está más desarrollada si se valora la
proporción de adultos que tienen una
cuenta bancaria también en sudáfrica y
en mauricio está muy desarrollado en los
servicios financieros aunque es en
áfrica del este donde ha aumentado más
la inclusión financiera concretamente en
kenia y en uganda y en el resto del
continente también la banca móvil ya y
el dinero móvil está en auge sobre todo
porque los bancos y las compañías
teleoperadoras ahora están favoreciendo
las transacciones digitales aún así cabe
tener en cuenta que áfrica es el
continente más empobrecido del mundo y
con más de 500 millones de personas en
situación de pobreza la inclusión
financiera puede crecer pero de forma
muy desigual
[Música]